we'll be in the left-hander core and on
the mound for the athletics it has been
a while since he has pitched but
he's still a very good pitcher and since
the a's are in the stretch of seven
consecutive games they're going to have
to use everybody and
her irving gets to the start today and i
think it's important one for him
swinging a line drive down the right
field line that's gonna drop
right in front of the right fielder
brown sharp line drive single good at
bad
lead off single here in the first nico
goodrum will be coming up swung on and
missed throws it by him
fastball in 93 goodrem kay's that'll
bring up wilson ramos
right down the middle ring him up strike
three call it perfect pitch two away
back to that case brings up jamer
candelario is the cleanup hitter
lifted right field angle toward the line
a routine play for seth brown
crossing the foul line he's there and he
makes the catch the tigers fail to score
with the a's coming up in the bottom
half young casey mize
the 23 year old right-hander from auburn
after two starts an 0-8-2
era sly ball to right that's where
robbie grossman is playing here today
one out ramon lauriano at the plate
ground ball to short boy that's a good
play by nico goodram
behind second base in the shift he
picked an in-between hop with a backhand
flips over to first
two up and two down that'll bring up
matt olson solston hitting 263 with a
couple of home runs three for seven
with two walks in the series olson has
gone from noble's two strikes to a full
count this is probably the critical
pitch because it is three and two
he's got a good fast ball see if he
challenges him and olson who can attack
a fastball
drill to right way back grossman will
turn and watch it fly
and no doubt a big-time home run by
olsen
he had to be looking for that fastball
give him credit for challenging and the
a's take a one-nothing lead
[Applause]
i wouldn't say well the left field jones
going back jones near the wall
jones sleeps up drops it bounces back
toward the infield
chapman's gonna round second chapman's
headed for third and he's gonna ease in
there with a triple
this ball was catchable hesitation that
first step and then he's trying
to time it he just misjudges that now
casey mize has to pitch out of a jam
the 1-2 is swinging the ground ball into
the shift fielded by willie castro on
the infield dirt an easy flip to scope
the splitter gets the easy ground ball
out a two out single for machine
aramis garcia the catcher looking for
his first asrbi
runner goes and the pitch is swung on a
fly ball left center jones is back
jones at the track he will turn and
watch and garcia
has hit it out his first athletics home
run
dreaded hanging slider if i could shut
my eyes and tell you that he's going to
be hit out of the ballpark
in the 8th second long ball already they
have a three nothing lead in the bottom
of the second
canna against myself kicks and throws
and mark throws one to left
jones going back at the track he will
turn and watch
that one fly home run derby for the a's
already
pitching is a lot like real estate it's
all about location the balls that
have been hit out have been up and out
over the plate
four nothing oakland now the tigers are
trying to mount something with two on
and one out as willie castro stands in
he swings and drives one to right back
onto this brown he's there to make the
catch above the cap
he'll come up firing back toward the
infield but good room will tag and
he'll hustle to third base and get there
often scope steps to the plate
need to get this bat going 3-2 swing at
a foul tip garcia holds on he went
upstairs and
got him with a fastball and now the
tigers little
two out rally in the fifth they have two
runners on that'll bring up nico goodrum
and now the 3-2 pitch once again is at
the knees ring him up fastball
strike three called a huge pitch for
irving he's have a can at third olson's
at first
chapman will check in infield back
looking for two and the pitch is a
ground ball double play ball taken by
the second baseman
and the flip to the shortstop and the
throw by castro is not in time and
scoring from third is canna
and his five nothing is in the fifth
five seven oh
for the athletics no runs four hits for
the tigers and wilson ramos
will lead it off bouncy ball back to
third backhand shot but has it plenty of
time throws the first one picked and
ramos
is retired he's out 5-3 chapman's right
there
he grabs the line drive matt chapman
did not have to move even an inch
outstanding defensive positioning
by the oklahoma's coaching staff playing
in a five ball on center field lauriano
angling toward right center he's right
there to make the catch and what a job
by
cole urban they've blanked the tigers
behind irvine on for his today
the first man out of the a's bullpen 2-2
swing and a miss fastball down and away
with good life
and grinder comes up empty seven
strikeouts for oakland pitching
0-2 swing at a miss just reared back
with some country hardball at 95
and blows away jones the inning is over
he has loaded the bases with walks
and you want to find your way into the
manager's doghouse
that is position number one joey menez
has
now faced nine batters in his 2021
season and he has walked six of the nine
batters
as [ __ ] moreland now comes to the plate
it's a check swing did he go the answer
is no it's ball four
and he walks in a run and that's the
last pitch he'll throw
maybe the last pitch he throws for a
while for aj hitch
as borland gets a gift rbi his fifth of
the year
and it's six nothing oakland alex lang
on and relief to the plate
and he spins one off the foot of grinder
kicks away from him that will score
olson
on a wild pitch to make it seven nothing
hard breaking ball that ricocheted off
of grinder had no
chance to smother it in the easy ad he
had another run without a hit
so jordan weems is the fourth pitcher in
the game for the a's and he will try to
get those final three outs
and he hits one in the air toward
markella
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
strike three two outs here in the night
machine charges on the run and that's
the ball game
so the a's pitching staff is starting to
become
the story second consecutive
shutout for the athletics and
hey they're over 500 thanks to their
seventh consecutive
win as they shut out the tigers this
afternoon in game three the series it's
just good baseball just
doing it uh pitching hitting all good
things
well you were on base three times again
today there was a conscious effort in
spring training we all took note of
to see more pitches to get ready to
adjust to that lead-off role
fair to say you're okay with the results
up to this point
yeah yeah it's it's still uh
feels different but um i'm telling
myself to just
just keep doing what i'm doing and keep
being myself and and that's good enough